PAUL KINLAN: Hello, everyone.
My name is Paul Kinlan.
This is me.
I'm a Chrome Developer
advocate on the mobile web team
here at Google.
And you can find me in all
the normal places, on Twitter,
Google+, and GitHub, and
a couple of other places.
I'm actually really
excited to be in Korea.
This is the furthest
east I've ever
been in the world,
which is pretty cool.
And we've only been here
for two or three days,
and we hope to go and
explore a little bit more
over the weekend, before
we move on to Tokyo.
And before I get
into the talk itself,
a lot of the reason
why we're here
is to understand more about
the Korean market, what
it means to be leading the
way in the mobile space.
What happens here is
going to happen elsewhere
in the rest of the world in
maybe two or three years' time,
especially with regards to
4G rollout for networks.
So what we learn
here, we can hopefully
apply to the rest of our
outreach work inside Chrome
Developer Relations.
So that's why we're here,
and I'll get started.
So the talk today is called
"Building fast mobile sites
with PageSpeed Mobile
Insights tool."
I need to work out how to
start this one properly.
But the interesting
thing is that we're
running this kind of
project called #perfmatters.
We think performance
is a feature
and should be planned in
from the start of your kind
of development cycle
and not thought
of as an addition,
a thing that you
do when you're testing
your application
or your website at the
end of your project.
And the reason why
we think this is
because the web isn't
getting that much faster.
OK, the network connection
speed is getting a lot quicker,
but the actual size of
pages, the page load time,
is actually only slowing down.
And you look at these
stats from 2012,
this was from Google Analytics.
The average page load time for
mobile was over 10 seconds.
And then we jump
forward to 2013,
and we see that, OK, maybe after
three seconds, 57% of consumers
say they're going to move
on to a different page.
But the important stat
here is that pages
are 8% slower than they
were in the summer of 2013.
So in the space of, say,
three or four months,
pages have gotten
nearly 10% slower.
And this is for a
variety of reasons.
Pages are bigger.
There's a lot more
things on them.
And developers probably
don't particularly
care about performance.
But it turns out users really
do care about performance.
They just don't
really tell anyone.
So the question I
have to ask and why
I have to think whether this
talk is important for you guys,
is-- I was looking at
the stats, that Korea
has got a hugely rolled
out, massive 4G network,
a percentage for
the population, more
than any other
country in the world.
And I need to work out
whether we can get developers
in Korea actually
caring about performance
and not just leaving
it to the network
operators and the phones
to actually get faster.
Because if we can't get you
guys excited about performance,
then how do we get the
rest of the world excited
about performance as well,
especially when it comes
to getting data down the wire
or down the phone as quick
as possible?
So I want to look at this
idea of the life of a request.
And I've got two columns, a
3G column and a 4G column.
And I know, looking at
this now, you probably
can't see the actual numbers.
But we see that on
average, the round trip
time for a DNS lookup on a
3G phone is 200 milliseconds,
so a fifth of a second.
The actual connection
to the actual host,
once you've actually
resolved the domain name,
takes another 200 milliseconds.
And a HTTP request
itself probably
takes 200 milliseconds.
And that's not
including the time
it might take to boot up the
radio on the phone, which
for 3G, it can be anywhere
between 200 milliseconds
and two and a half seconds.
So when we're trying to get
data and pages down to the user
as quickly as possible, on
3G, we've got a real problem.
And then on 4G, it's
actually way better.
It's 80 milliseconds,
normally, round trip time
for most operations.
So you have a lot more
budget to play with.
But that number is a
little bit of a lie,
because if we think
about the slide before,
it said it takes about
10 seconds to load pages
even on mobile.
They were obviously taken
in the idea of a 3G network.
There were no 4G networks
when these stats were out.
But the actual difference is
maybe 4G is three times faster.
So you might get about
six or seven seconds.
This 240 milliseconds is
just one HTTP request.
And I'm going to talk
a little bit later
about the size of pages.
But the reason why
pages are going slower
is because there's more
content on those pages, more
requests coming out from them.
So this 240 milliseconds
is the best case time
that you would probably get
for every single request that
comes out of your page.
And we're going to talk about
what web requests on your page
mean to the actual page life
cycle in a minute, as well,
and why we think you
should prioritize
certain types of
content over others
and certain types of
requests over others.
Because at Google,
we actually believe
you can get a page to a user in
about a second, even on mobile.
And I know Paul Irish alluded
to it earlier on in the DevTools
talk, is we think it
is possible for you
to build experiences
on the web which
are 10 times faster than
they are today on mobile.
So getting content
out within one second.
And hopefully,
with this talk, we
will show you how you
can start to do that,
or how you can think
about planning to do that.
So how can we make
fast mobile sites?
That works.
I had a big spelling mistake
in this about five minutes ago,
so I'm just trying to
make sure this is correct.
We want to show you today
how you can make fast sites.
We've developed a tool called
PageSpeed Mobile Insights.
I don't know whether any of
you know about PageSpeed.
Does anyone know
about PageSpeed?
One or two people, a few people.
So the PageSpeed team is part
of the Making the Web Fast Team.
They want to make the
web as fast as possible,
make it easy for developers
to build quick sites,
so you don't have to worry
about how to optimize your site.
But one of the
things that we find
is that developers,
like we said before,
don't really care about
performance because they don't
really know they've
always got a problem.
And the PageSpeed
Mobile Insights tool
is designed to show you
that you potentially
have problems on your site with
regards to a mobile device,
and then also how
to go and fix them.
So it doesn't tell you
you've got problems,
and you need to go and
work out what to do.
It tries to tell
you exactly what you
should do to make
your page fast.
So a couple other
checks, and we're only
going to cover three or four
of them in this talk today,
but they're the highest
priority, most critical
features or kind of
problems that you
can find on a web page
which directly affect
the performance
for the end user.
And they're ordered
kind of in priority.
Number of redirects.
We'll talk about what
that means in a minute.
But basically, any
redirect slows your site
down significantly.
Poor compression
and minification.
You'd be really surprised
about the number of sites
that don't turn on
compression on their service.
Scripts, CSS blocking, and
critical rendering path.
This is relatively complex.
And we're going to
talk about it later.
And I know some of you will
be quite familiar with this.
But we're going to talk about
what it means to basically
get content visible on the
screen within a second.
It might not be the entire page
that is loaded within a second,
but the user has this
perception of performance
because they see something on
the screen within a second.
And then there's obviously
usage of caching.
Caching is important,
but we're not
going to go into
it today because we
don't have a huge
amount of time.
So if you want to have a
play with PageSpeed Insights,
it's at the link.
And I will share this
out a little bit later,
but I'm going to try and
give you a little demo.
I have prepared this page just
in case the demo doesn't work,
so I can kind of run through it.
But essentially, it's a
tool where you put a URL in,
and it will go off
and analyze the site.
If you just give me two seconds
while I-- don't do that.
Break out.
Jump in.
And this is basically
the summary of results.
So HTML5 Rocks is a developer
resource that we own and run.
And we are basically
trying to tell people
how to build great mobile sites.
And one of the things
that you'll find
is that we need to be a
great mobile site ourselves.
So we regularly analyze
our site to make sure
that we're meeting all
the criteria that we
say developers should follow.
And as you can see,
we've got kind of a score
here, 73 out of 100 for
mobile, 89 out of 100--
let me just zoom in.
89 out of 100 for desktop.
It's the mobile one that we're
interested in at the moment.
And you can basically
see a whole series
of kind of suggestions
about things
that the PageSpeed service
has done and detected
problems with our
site and how we
should go about resolving them.
So the first one is eliminate
render-blocking JavaScript
and CSS.
And I'm going to dive
into that a little bit
later about what that means.
But it's one of the
most critical things
that you can do to improve
the performance of your site.
Avoid landing page redirects.
That's a big one.
HTML5 Rocks has got
a bit of an issue.
We do two redirects to get the
user to the correct content,
which is a problem,
and we need to fix.
And the server response time.
If you want to get your site
out to the user within a second,
you have to deal with
the fact that even on 4G,
you've probably got 1,000
milliseconds minus the 240
milliseconds available to kind
of go and build your site.
So maybe 3/4 of a second to
actually build your site.
So we're probably OK
on 4G at the moment,
but on a 3G network,
we only really
have 200 milliseconds
to actually
be able to respond with the HTML
from our server to the client.
And there's a whole set of
other criteria about enabling
compression, which we're
passing, and we're doing fine.
So if I was a developer, I'd go
and look at those three or four
different criteria to
actually go and check.
Our screen shrunk.
There we are.
And obviously, this is
the Korean translation.
I'm presuming it means
exactly the same thing
as what I've just
shown you before.
But it basically
prioritizes the things
that we think you should fix.
And I believe I got this right.
I was looking for Korean
phrases the other day.
And I found this one,
"Well begun is half done."
Is that correct?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PAUL KINLAN: OK, good.
Maybe it's not lying.
So I think actually
the Korean phrase,
the way I understand
it, is quite optimistic.
You do things well at the
start, the rest of the project
is a lot easier to
complete, basically.
And in the UK, we have
this thing that says
"Proper planning prevents
poor performance."
Actually, it's got a swear word
in between, which I've deleted.
So it's six P's.
But we, as a country,
are pretty negative.
So we basically tell you,
you're doing things wrong,
not you want do things right.
I want to say, the
reason why I've got this
is because the
PageSpeed Insights
tool is very retrospective.
The site is live on the internet
and telling you problems
that you've got.
And what we really
want you to do
is take the advice that we're
going to tell you today and use
it at the start
of your projects,
so you don't have to worry about
the performance of your site
so much as the
project progresses
and as you go to completion.
And that's how I'm interpreting
this phrase, at least.
So redirects.
We think these are one of the
most important kind of issues.
And I'll tell you
why in a second.
Obviously, we saw
the result before.
HTML5 Rocks has got two
different redirects.
We go from html5rocks.com
to www.html5rocks,
and then we forward you on to
the language translation site.
So it's got two different types
of redirects, a domain redirect
and then a directory redirect.
And both are not good.
And if we get rid of
them, we'll actually
improve the performance of
our site quite significantly.
The reason why
redirects are bad is
because they can double latency
because, especially with a DNS
redirect, which is this, you
basically go from one domain
and forward them to another.
So you go from,
say, html5rocks.com
to www.html5rocks.com.
Now where this is most
prevalent on the web
is when a user comes
in on a mobile phone
to a desktop-based site,
and the server goes,
we know you're on a mobile.
We'll directly you
to the m dot site,
the mobile version of the site.
Now this is actually
bad because you
have to do a DNS lookup
at the start, which
is about on 3G at least,
probably 200 milliseconds.
Make the TCP connection, which
is another 200 milliseconds.
You probably won't
get some content,
but you'll get the redirect.
And because it's
a different domain
that you're redirecting
to, you have
to do another DNS lookup, which
is the same process again.
It's another 200 milliseconds
for a DNS lookup,
and then another
200 milliseconds
to actually make the
connection to the server.
And then you probably
go and get the content.
Now we actually have
two different types
of redirects on
additional HTML5 Rocks.
The third one is the
directory lookup.
It's not as slow.
It's kind of a
little bit better,
because you get to take
advantage of the fact
that you don't have to do
another set of DNS resolution,
and you don't have to
necessarily always have
to make a new TCP connection.
You can just pretty much use the
same connection that you're on.
But you have to have the server
enabled for HTTP pipelining.
But in our case, we
actually found this here.
This green line here is
actually a bug in HTML5 Rocks.
And I think Paul Irish
showed you WebPagetest
a little earlier on today.
This is the same tool.
You put WebPagetest
in, and it tests it
from all around
the world and shows
you the latency and the request
time for a number of things.
And we've actually found a
bug with HTML5 Rocks on this,
because we send you the
content and then redirect.
Or we don't send
you the content,
we generate all the
content and then
redirect you to something
which is different, again.
So we've got a bug.
And we found that,
actually, with this tool.
Well, redirects are
pretty bad, and you
should try to ignore them or
try to move away from them.
Now I understand that
if you're developing
an application or a site, and
you've already got it live,
then you're not going to
be able to really change
the infrastructure of your site.
It's a big job to go to a
fully responsive design site.
But if you're starting
a brand new project,
I really do consider a
responsive based solution,
even if it's a server
responsive solution--
and I know there was a
question earlier on today about
whether you should do
user agent detection.
Sometimes, it might be the best
of a bad solution, the best
option in a bad
solution, essentially.
Because even if you
do a server detection,
don't do the redirect.
Send the different content out.
And as long as you've got the
correct kind of search engine
headers, then you're not going
to suffer from SEO too much,
or SEO issues, or Search
Engine Optimization issues.
But the preference
from Google, and you'll
see this all across Google, is
go to a fully responsive design
site.
But we understand that's
not always practical,
and sometimes you have to
do things on the server.
The best thing to do
is just not redirect.
Have the logic
which separates out
the two sites behind the
scenes and then serve
the correct content
to the user that way.
It's not great, but
it's a better solution
than the redirect.
So yeah, save the user's time.
No redirects.
If we did this on
HTML5 Rocks, we
would probably say 300
or 400 milliseconds
in the standard
request life cycle,
just by making sure that we do
manage the redirects correctly.
So compression is
the next subject.
It's never a really
interesting topic, compression.
But it's one of those ones
where developers never do it,
it seems.
We never seem to care about it.
And I think you should.
This is a site.
This is actually a
UK government site.
So the NHS, the National
Health Service, has got a site.
It's not mobile optimized,
and it wouldn't actually
matter if it was mobile
optimized, because they don't
follow any of the
basic practices at all.
So they've got a
whole lot of issues.
The one that we're going
to talk about right
now is the compression.
You probably can't
see it, but there's
673 kilobytes of
extra content that
doesn't need to be
downloaded on this site.
Well, I'll rephrase it.
It's content that does
need to be downloaded,
but could be compressed,
and you wouldn't actually
ever download that
again, essentially,
that 670 kilobytes.
That's not far off
from a megabyte's worth
of extra content which was
needlessly piped down the site.
Now the interesting
thing is that they also
have a problem
with minification.
They don't actually strip
out extraneous content
from their page.
So these are CSS files
with extra spaces
which aren't needed, tabs,
JavaScript with longer variable
names than need to be.
PageSpeed Insights will
go through and work out
potentially how
much data you could
save by following proper
minification rules.
And in this case, for the
National Health Service,
if they had minification
and ignored the compression,
they could save 150
kilobytes quite quickly,
which on a 3G network, is
actually quite significant.
If we go back and we
look at the compression,
if they turned compression
on as well, that's
another 600 kilobytes extra that
they save, which, especially
on 3G-- it's probably
not so bad on 4G--
is actually a pretty good thing.
The interesting thing
as well, and we'll
talk about this
later, is that they
make about 30 requests per page.
So there's 30 extra
requests, HTTP requests,
that have to go
out to the server
to be processed
for every request.
And that's not a good thing.
So our guidance is minify all
CSS, JavaScript, and HTML.
The minification is
great because you
don't lose any of the semantic
meaning of the content.
So the CSS will be the same
CSS, mean the same thing.
The JavaScript will
mean the same thing
and execute in the same way.
And likewise with
the HTML, you're
just removing
content that doesn't
need to be sent to the user.
And our other piece
of advice is turn
on gzip for all
text-based content.
You can turn it on
for images, but you
won't save that much space.
Normally with text
content, you can
save in the region of
about 50% of the bandwidth
that you would send out.
And just, I suppose,
as a side note,
I have to say that
a lot of people
don't actually turn
on compression.
Httparchive.org, let
me just load it up.
If you've never
seen HTTP Archive,
it's a really-- let me
just-- there we are.
I'll fix that link.
But HTTP Archive
basically goes out
and scans probably about
a million URLs once
a week and indexes
and aggregates
every single request that
is sent by the browsers
that they automate.
And then they produce some
interesting statistics
off the back of this.
So they can tell you that
most of the content--
you can't see that
at the back, but most
of the content on
the web is images.
By far and away, the larger
proportion of content
is images.
They've got other kind of
really interesting stats
as well, like the average
individual response
size being around 95 kilobytes.
Now here we go.
Yep.
That by itself is
not that interesting.
It's kind of cool that you can
see the average response size.
But what they also do is
they dump all the data
into a service
that we run called,
I think it's-- what
it's called again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PAUL KINLAN: I can't remember
the name of the project.
The database which we
can query, not compute.
Doesn't matter.
I'll share the link later.
But essentially,
there's a big database
where they drop an index
of every single page
the HTTP Archive analyzes
and every request
that that page makes.
So if a page makes
30 requests, we
have that database
kind of stored.
And you, as a
normal developer who
might be interested
in performance,
can go out and actually
query that information.
And what I'll do is
I'll share a tweet out
later around the
name of the service
and what you can do to do this.
But I did some of this kind
of basic aggregation before.
Yesterday it was from
last week's data set.
And I looked at the CSS
files, the HTML files,
and the JavaScript files.
And it's pretty clear that
this 39% of the website that
don't bother compressing--
or 39% of the requests that
go out from the browser-- that
when they find the CSS file,
they'll download the full file,
and it won't be compressed.
There's no compression
turned on for that.
That's pretty huge.
40% of the web doesn't
bother compressing CSS file.
And HTML is worse.
Normal pages, index pages that
you go to and navigate around,
they don't turn compression
on for nearly half of the web.
That's pretty crazy, especially
when you're on a mobile device.
Now the interesting thing is
actually, JavaScript is 16%,
so around about 84% of the
web compresses JavaScript.
And when you dive
into this, it's
because a lot of JavaScript
solutions are based on CDNs.
So Google have got
jQuery and a whole lot
of other kind of
frameworks hosted on a CDN.
And those CDNs will make sure
that content is compressed.
HTML and CSS, normally
if it's your own server,
you probably haven't
turned the compression on.
And I think that's crazy.
In most cases, actually turning
compression on, especially
in Apache and Nginx, is a
one-line configuration change,
and it doesn't really impact
the speed of your service
at all, from a
processing standpoint.
So we also do a lot of
analysis on PageSpeed Insights
to scripts and CSS.
And the specific piece
of analysis that we do
is a thing called
render-blocking
JavaScript and CSS.
It turns out the
way that the browser
gets JavaScript and
CSS from the server
has a dramatic impact
on the performance
of your application.
And we try and tell
you as a developer
the things that stop the
layout from happening,
the things with
regards to your CSS
and JavaScript which
will cause your page not
be painted to the
screen quickly.
And this is Google Analytics.
Like even some of our services
don't have a great kind of-- we
don't follow our
guidance is, I suppose,
what I'm trying to say
in a lot of these cases.
And we're going to talk about
what render blocking means
in a minute, or now, in fact.
I heard a quote, and
I'm trying to find out
who actually said it.
But they said the fastest sites
will have no scripts and CSS.
Which is true.
If you just send raw HTML
to a service or to a user,
it's going to be really
quick because there's
no subsequent requests.
But you're going to be
pretty bored on the internet.
There's no interactivity
or anything available.
And it's going to
look pretty ugly.
So you have to use JavaScript.
You have to use CSS.
And that's where the actual
problems with performance
and getting data
down to the client
so that they can use your
website or application actually
happen.
So we have this thing called
the critical rendering path.
And basically,
it's a combination
of the DOM tree, which
is your HTML structure,
and the render tree.
Now this is a little
bit hard to understand,
and I know people at the back
won't be able to see properly,
but there's essentially two
core components to the browser.
There's the DOM structure, which
is, if you look at this section
here, which is your document,
your HTML element, your head
title, the body, the structure--
the semantic HTML, essentially,
that describes the page.
And then there's
this render tree,
which is essentially a
combination of the DOM
tree and the CSS object model.
Now the CSS object
model is the thing
that essentially presents
the content from the DOM tree
to the user.
And the two have to be
done and complete around
about the same time,
otherwise you don't actually
get any content.
The thing to note about
this and why it's important,
and why this actually
blocks the rendering,
is because imagine you've
got a HTML document,
and there's an image right
at the bottom of the page.
And that's in the DOM structure.
It's the last thing
that the browser gets.
It's at the bottom of the DOM.
If you have your CSS, your
CSS might actually say,
that image is hoisted to
the very top of the page
because it's got the
absolute positioning.
Use position absolute, 0, 0.
And it's pushed right
to the top of the page.
Now if the browser didn't
wait till the DOM was complete
and the CSS object
model was completed,
then you would see the image
pop in at the bottom of the page
and then jump up to
the top of the page,
and that's not what any
browser vendor actually
wants to happen.
So there are these two kind
of competing structures
inside the browser which you
have to get exactly right.
And we're going
to talk about how
you can ruin that
experience completely.
So this is the HTML5 parser
roughly as it's defined.
I say roughly as it's
defined because it's not
exactly how browsers work.
But essentially, the browser
or the document parser
will go through all
the HTML and make
this kind of nested
structure inside its own DOM
representation.
And what it does is when
it detects a script,
it basically says, well,
this script is important.
It's critical to the
application or site.
I'm going to not bother passing
the rest of the document.
I'm going to wait for the
script to actually return
and load and execute
inside the browser.
Now that actually stops
this kind of subsequent--
you'll notice that
there's a link
element there with a style.
That stops that
from being loaded.
So basically, before you can
get anything to the screen,
that script has
to be downloaded.
It's not quite how it works.
There are a lot of browsers that
have a speculative parser which
will go off and start to
download other scripts as well.
But fundamentally, if you
have a script element,
it has to stop doing what it's
doing, process the script,
and then get back to it.
Which, when you
think about trying
to get data like the page to
the user as quickly as possible,
it's pretty bad.
Imagine you have to go off
to get the jQuery library
before you can actually
see anything on the screen.
And if that takes
200 milliseconds
to get from somewhere,
that's 200 milliseconds
lost where the user won't
actually see the page.
So it's pretty interesting.
So yes, scripts
block the parser.
Most scripts or
old style scripts--
this is the Google +1 button.
Most scripts where you have,
for instance, social widgets,
whether it's Twitter,
Google+, those type of things,
if you don't use them correctly,
you can really slow down
the performance of your page.
And the reason why
the script actually
does a whole lot of
stuff-- the scripts block
is one, because
it has to execute.
But at the same time,
there's a potential chance
that the browser
or the developer
might have included
document.write inside there as
well.
And if they included
document.write,
it has to go off
and reparse the DOM.
So that's why, for
instance, without
the speculative
parsing, at least,
you basically have to wait
for the script to execute,
which, again, obviously
slows down the page.
Now the interesting thing
is that the browsers
have made a decision as well
that if you actually download
any JavaScript, you probably
have to wait for the CSS
to download as well.
So you might have all
the-- how to say this.
You've got the link
elements, and you're
downloading your style sheets,
and they're getting downloaded.
And you have maybe three
or four different style
sheets in place.
Now the JavaScript might
have a get computer property
or get computer style
which would return
the position of the element
inside the render tree.
When that actually runs,
you want it to be accurate.
You don't want it
to say, well, you
know what, the CSS
hasn't downloaded.
So the image that is at the
bottom of the page actually
is still at the
bottom of the page.
When in actual
fact, the developer,
when the CSS was
applied, wanted the image
to be at the top of the page.
So browsers like
Firefox, for instance,
basically completely block if
there's any JavaScript actually
being downloaded,
because they want
to ensure that any CSS
style sheets that are being
downloaded are actually
downloaded and applied
at the correct time so it's
as accurate as possible.
And that is probably
one of the reasons
why having JavaScript
in line-- well,
JavaScript that requests
a page at the top,
in your head element, is
actually a really bad thing.
And actually, it turns
out that rendering is also
blocked on CSS.
They don't want this kind of
flash of white unstyled content
appear, happening to
the user every time.
So in many cases, they will not
display anything on the page
until the link
elements that its found
have actually been downloaded.
So yeah, JavaScript can
block the DOM construction.
JavaScript can also be blocked
from downloading and executing
correctly on CSS waiting
to be downloaded.
And rendering is always
blocked on CSS, in most cases.
So if you don't have your
CSS files downloaded in time,
you won't see anything
on the screen.
So the interesting thing
I want to talk about
is this idea of the
perception of performance,
which is a trend that's
happening in web development
at the moment.
It's kind of a-- how to say it.
It's a recognition that we
can't break the laws of physics.
We can't get data
delivered any faster to us.
We can't have the data--
we can't basically
break the speed
of light, I think
is the easiest way
of saying things.
So we have to fake
a lot of things.
We have to basically tell the
user, something is happening,
even when it is happening, but
they don't know it's happening.
It's really weird.
And I'll explain it properly.
The British love to queue.
I was in the airport, and
I was greeted with this.
There was some fog.
The planes couldn't take off.
So there was basically
backlogs of traffic and queue
for people.
And I was in this
queue for three hours,
and I stayed in the
queue for three hours
because I wanted to
get my next flight.
And by the time I
got to the front,
all the flights had gone, and I
couldn't get a flight to Berlin
at the time.
So I had to go back home.
And it was really annoying.
And I had just stood,
like everyone else,
for three hours,
waiting politely
to get to this point of trying
to be able to get a ticket.
And I was really annoyed
throughout the whole process.
And it's because I
knew I was there.
I couldn't do anything.
Nothing was happening.
There was no one to speak
to, to help you out and help
you get to where you're going.
Nothing was happening.
My perception of
the performance was
I was just stuck in a queue
waiting for absolutely ages.
Now when you look at
modern airports and the way
they're starting
to design airports
is they recognize that
actually, in airports, there's
lots of queues, and people
stand around waiting, doing
absolutely nothing.
So one of the things that
they're starting to do
is make you walk a
lot, lot further.
You'll get off your plane, and
you'll go down a long alleyway,
and you'll keep walking and
keep walking and keep walking.
And then you'll go
through some security
and then go and
collect your bags.
And what it makes you think
is, well, you get to the end,
and your bags are
waiting on the carousel.
You pick them up, and
then you take them home.
You're like, that was
really, really quick service.
That was brilliant.
I got off the
plane, and the bags
were waiting for me
just as I got there.
But actually, in
fact, and I just
realized you can't
read this-- in fact,
your bags take the exact
same amount of time
to get from the airplane
to the carousel.
It's just that in that
intermediate time,
you've been doing something
else other than standing around.
So it turns out people complain
a lot less when they have
to walk further
and do something.
And that's what we want people
to do with web development.
If you're building
sites and services,
you can actually get
something to the screen
as quickly as possible,
make the user think
that the site is
fully interactable
and you can actually
interact with it.
But actually, then,
kind of downloading
the rest of the content
behind the scenes
and bring it out as
quickly as possible.
So it's kind of an
interesting kind of paradigm.
And I want to talk about
in two different ways.
The first is the DNS problem.
As sites get heavier
and heavier and heavier,
they use more and
more external scripts.
They refer to more and
more external domains.
They might have social widgets,
whether it's a Google+ widget
or a Twitter widget,
for instance.
And we saw earlier on
that a DNS connection,
it can take up to
200 milliseconds
on 3G and 80 milliseconds on 4G.
This is a really big
problem, especially when
you look at this.
There's, on average, 17 external
references, external sites
per page now on the web,
which is just crazy.
There's 17 DNS
lookups that you have
to do every time
you load a page.
So the perception
of performance,
you can't really
get around the fact
that you want these
social widgets and all
these interactive kind of
components on your page.
And someone else
provides them, so you
want to do a thing
called DNS prefetch.
Now Firefox and
Chrome implement this.
But basically what
happens is, right
at the very top
of your document,
you put a link element in
with a href of the domain
that you want to pre-resolve.
And what basically happens
is the browser goes,
hey, we're going to get
something from twitter.com.
Let's go and resolve
twitter.com to make sure
that the DNS is not going
to be the problem when
it comes to
downloading the script.
And the example I use
here is the BBC News site.
I was in our Korea
office yesterday,
and I was looking at
the BBC News site.
And it took about 10
or 15 seconds to load.
And I know the BBC is
a really good site.
In the UK, it's probably
about 100 milliseconds
to load the entire site.
And I looked at the way
that they've actually
structured their page.
And each of these scripts are
normally on a different domain.
They shard all the
scripts across domains.
And the DNS lookup up was
taking 139 milliseconds.
They don't do any of the
prefetching that you can do.
And if they had done
the prefetching,
then maybe the first
request would still
have to do the 150 milliseconds
kind of DNS resolution.
But all these other
subsequent requests
are all on different domains.
Well, the browser would have
gone off and gone, well,
I'm going to get
these ahead of time.
And then they're all
pre-resolved and ready
in place.
And it's a relatively
simple thing
that you can do to your page
to kind of boost the perceived
performance.
You don't actually
really changed
the real performance
of the page.
But the fact is, the
browser's going off
to do something ahead of time
that the user doesn't actually
see that work happening.
And it's pretty interesting.
It's pretty cool.
And it's easy to implement.
And the next is above the fold.
And I know Paul Irish talked
about this earlier on as well.
The above the fold
content is everything
you see in the very first
screen's worth of content.
What the browser actually sees,
and I know it's very small,
the browser sees the entire
page, the entire DOM,
all the images,
all the CSS that's
applicable for the entire page.
And the question
that you have to ask
is, can we just
download what's needed
at the top of the page
and then a little bit
later, once it's
displayed, download
the rest of the content?
Well, not the
content, but the CSS
and the JavaScript that is
applicable just to this bit.
You don't change the
amount of content
that is being
downloaded to the user.
You're just changing
the perception of speed
because you're saying, actually,
this first piece of content
here is the most critical,
the most important,
and we'll get that out to the
user as quickly as possible.
So when we want to optimize
in CSS, there's one quick win.
And if I was working for the
PageSpeed team, which I'm not,
the only thing that
they would ever suggest
is to install either
mod_pagespeed or
nginx_pagespeed, because
it's going to do everything
automatically that I'm
going to show you now.
The first, obviously these
are just bullet points.
And I'm really sorry that
they're bullet points,
but they're just
a list of things
that every developer should
do when they're actually
building a site.
Put your CSS early
in the document,
put it before a script so
the scripts don't block.
Actually, you probably
should put your scripts
at the end of the
document itself.
Make sure you minify, compress,
and cache all your CSS files.
That's the best
thing that you can
do for the user in that case.
And then generally reduce
the number of requests.
We saw from the BBC before
they're making-- well,
this is JavaScript.
They also have about four
or five different CSS files
that they download as well.
Just concatenate
them into one file.
And then inline in the
head where possible.
And the inline in
the head element
is what we're going
to talk about next.
Well, actually, it's not.
I lied.
I'm sorry.
So the first one
is use only the CSS
that is needed for the page.
If anyone's used Bootstrap,
the CSS framework for making
nice looking applications,
it's 120 kilobytes
in size, which is pretty big.
But most applications
don't use the entire range
of functionality from Bootstrap.
And some experimentation
that we've done,
where we've built
an application,
went through every single
page in that application
to look at the very
specific CSS that we used,
we managed to reduce that
file down to 11 kilobytes.
And you'll see this better
when I share the slides,
but this is the
code that we used.
It's a small piece of JavaScript
which walks through DOM
and then, for every
DOM element, works out
what CSS rules are
applicable and then
just saves them to a file.
Which is pretty cool.
We've basically
reduced the size to 10%
of the size of the
original file just
by being smart about
how we actually
want to serve up that content.
There's another, simpler way.
I don't know whether Paul
Irish showed it before,
but there's an Audits
panel in DevTools basically
that just lists all the
CSS which is not used.
If you find some CSS that's
not used on the page,
you can pretty much
safely strip that out.
And this is the one about
inline critical CSS.
The critical CSS is
the content-- the CSS
that only applies to things
above the fold, which
is basically the content
in the first screen's
worth of your page
on your mobile phone.
Now it's a little
bit more complex,
but the reason why
this is important
is because if you
inline the content,
you're not making a
request at the time you're
trying to get content to the
screen to an external CSS file.
You don't have to
wait for that request
to complete to bring it back in.
Now that's really cool
because it stops blocking
and helps you get the content
visible on the user's device.
But it's actually
really hard to work out
what is visible above
the fold at any one time.
And this is the technique
that we use at the moment.
If you go to my
blog, paul.kinlan.me,
I explain it a little
bit more there.
But essentially, we
walk the DOM again,
and we look to see whether
it's in the viewport
at any particular
time, like if it's
in the top part of the viewport.
And that's all it
is, but it's not
100% accurate at the moment.
And we're trying
to work on that.
But it's a good heuristic
that you can use.
And this is actually an
example of what it looks like.
I know Paul Irish talked about
it a little bit earlier on.
But this is the inlining
of the content which
is only applicable
for above the fold.
So above the fold stops here.
Anything beneath
this would not be
on the first part, the first
screen's worth of content.
So basically, we've
just analyzed the fact
that the body
element is important,
the h1 element is important,
and the div is important for us.
We've worked out the
CSS that is applicable.
And then we just
basically push that
into the style
element at the top.
So no request to
an external service
is going out from
the head, which
means that we can display this
content in just one request.
So you have to ask the question,
what about the rest of the CSS?
Well, you basically subtract
the two sets of property
or the two sets of
CSS style rules,
and you have a link rel
stylesheet at the bottom.
You'll potentially get a
flash of unstyled content
if the user scrolls,
and they scroll
past the link rel, which
has not been downloaded.
But generally, you can
get content to the screen
really, really quickly
with this technique.
And it's pretty cool.
Optimizing scripts
is another one.
We know that scripts block the
rendering quite significantly.
So what are the techniques that
you can use to improve this?
Well, again, if I was working
for the mod_pagespeed team,
or the PageSpeed team, I
would just tell everyone
to install mod_pagespeed
or nginx_pagespeed.
But I know that everyone
can't control their deployment
environment and don't want to
install new server software.
So we're going to show
you how to actually do
some of this stuff now.
But again, it's exactly the
same as CSS, optimizing for CSS.
You need to deliver it to the
user as quickly as possible.
You need to compress it,
you need to minify it,
and you need to reduce
the number of requests
that go out from your page.
And JavaScript is normally is
the one where there's normally
a lot of extra DNS
resolutions applied
because the JavaScript will
be on different content
distribution networks.
So in this case, using DNS
prefetch for your scripts
is actually probably
a pretty good thing.
But make sure you
remove all scripts
from the critical render path.
Try and have no script
above any area that
will be displayed on the page
in the very first screen's
worth of content.
I know it's hard to do.
You might want to do some
interaction with the DOM
at that time.
But just try and defer
as much as possible
because it really does slow
down the speed of your page.
So you can get around
it to some extent.
I might actually have
the syntax wrong.
But you can use async.
So there's an attribute
at the end called async,
which is available in
the script elements.
Now async basically says, I'm
going to download this script,
and I'm not going
to block the DOM
parser from doing
the rest of its work.
But what this actually
means at the same time
is that you can have three
or four different scripts
with the async
attribute applied,
and it will download them
and execute them in any order
that they come back.
So if script A becomes
before script B-- sorry,
I'll rephrase it.
If script B comes
before script A,
then script B will
execute before A.
And if you have a dependency
on two or three scripts,
you don't want to use the async
attribute because you can't
guarantee the
order of execution.
And you shouldn't
really use it if you're
going to manipulate the DOM.
If you've got
document.write or any kind
of other thing in place
there, it's really bad
because what might
actually happen,
if you've got a very large
document like the HTML5 spec,
for instance, it's
multiple megabytes in size,
you might have some
JavaScript which downloads,
and then it executes.
The DOM element that
you want to interact
with at that time
might not be available,
might not be on the
screen, just purely
because the JavaScript
was actually
quite small in comparison
to the actual HTML document.
So to kind of get around
the unordered execution
of asynchronous scripts,
there's a defer attribute.
And defer does something
similar to async.
It basically says, you can go
off and download this file,
and I'll continue
parsing the DOM
and let all the CSS apply and
a whole lot of other stuff.
But it actually blocks
the onload event.
It basically waits for all
the scripts to complete,
executes them in the order
that they were specified
in your script to ensure
consistency-- script
A executes before
script B, which
executes before
script C-- and you can
ensure some consistency there.
It's kind of useful
for taking out
the blocking aspect of scripts.
But again, you
don't particularly
want to rely on interacting
with any DOM at that time.
You want to wait till it's page
onload and then kind of get
the content back out.
So you can defer, and that will
actually speed up your page.
One of the things that
a lot of Google services
tend to recommend is
you literally just put
all your scripts at the end of
the page and wait for the wait
for the scripts to execute
then, rather than using async
or defer.
So what are some of the
tools that you can use?
Well obviously,
DevTools is one of them.
DevTools is really
cool because you
can connect either to
your desktop machine
or directly to your network,
to your mobile phone.
And what this means is that
if you're on your network,
if you connect DevTools
to your mobile phone,
you actually see the network
that all the rest of your users
would see, essentially.
All the requests that happen,
the latencies that you see,
would be probably pretty similar
across the rest of your users
on mobile as well,
which is pretty cool.
But that gives you a
good, strong indication
about what's blocking,
when it's blocking,
and how to go and fix
these things as well.
The next is PageSpeed
Insights extension,
which I'll see if
I can demo briefly.
There we go.
Here's one here.
Let me refresh.
Hopefully this works.
That didn't work, did it?
News.bbc.
Come on.
See, the BBC takes
a while to load.
A lot of their
servers are in London.
No.
OK, so you can tell this
is code I've written.
It doesn't work.
Let's go back to
the presentation.
So essentially,
what would happen
is every page that you
visit, the extension goes
off and checks the page against
PageSpeed Insight service,
which will then give
you this report.
It'll basically tell the size of
the HTML, the data in the HTML,
the total size of all
the images on the page,
and a whole lot
of other features.
But it also gives
you a screenshot
of what it looks like
on a mobile device
and the suggested
fixes that you can do.
So if you've got
a site, and you're
kind of testing your own site,
and you're navigating around
it, this extension's pretty
cool because everywhere you go,
the extension checks basically
the mobile performance of it.
So it's pretty cool.
And that's the link
I've got there.
It's 9TtTKs.
It's pretty cool.
The next is Mobile
Speed Monitor as well.
This is another service
that we've written,
which is a Chrome App, which
is what Pete LePage talked
about earlier today.
You can basically put
a whole series of URLs.
And every 10
minutes, it'll go off
and run some analysis on it.
So you can basically
see and check,
for a whole range of
pages inside your site,
whether they're performing
well and whether they're
consistently performing
well as well.
So it gives you some
warning ahead of time
that something might
have gone wrong
if you've just deployed
some software onto the web.
So in summary,
delivering performance,
it should be a feature.
It's not for a lot of
developers at the moment.
It's something
that you go and fix
at the end of your
development project.
We want you to kind
of go and think
about how you build your
applications ahead of time.
So use PageSpeed Insights
to get actionable advice.
PageSpeed Insights will
tell you all the things
that it thinks are
wrong with your page
and how to go and fix it.
But always ensure that
you do the basics right.
Try not to use redirects
if possible at all.
I know you can't get
away from it sometimes.
But just follow that
piece of guidance first.
Try never to redirect the
user to another domain
or another page.
Always concatenate, minify,
and compress your scripts.
We didn't talk about it today,
but optimize your images.
Images can be optimized far more
than what we think they can be.
You can change the compression
settings on your JPEG files.
And you will save a lot
in bandwidth for the user.
Obviously, compress everything
and cache heavily as well.
And one of the areas is, at
the start of your project,
plan for inling critical CSS.
I don't think anyone
in this audience
is going to go off
tonight and inline
critical CSS on their web pages.
For an established project,
it's just not feasible.
But if you're starting to
build your project now,
you can start to think about how
you can get those inline styles
into the head element and
then kind of break that up so
that the rest of the
CSS is loaded later on,
and you're getting the content
for the user on the screen
as quickly as possible.
And we say deliver above the
fold content in the first 15
kilobytes.
There's a very specific reason.
If you set up your
server correctly,
you can send 10 TCP packets
out with 15 kilobytes
worth of content before even
having to send a response back.
That is actually a really
hard one to even solve,
and we don't even do it
ourselves at the moment.
So just try and get as much
of the content out to the user
as quickly as
possible, and get it
on the screen within a second,
is our overall guidance.
And that's the end.
I finished.
That's it.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL KINLAN: I've
got one final thing.
If you have any feedback
on any of these features,
I know we haven't got
time for questions.
Paulkinlan@google.com, or
I'm on Twitter and GitHub
and everywhere else.
Just send me the feedback.
Don't worry about
whether you can or can't.
Just send me the
data and send me
the information that you have.
It'd be really cool.
[APPLAUSE]